welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Star Wars
and or episode nine yes I do look and
sound a bit different here because I'm
currently in a different corner of the
blue dungeon at new rockstars HQ I'll be
back in my little rat hole in a few days
but my mission is the same here to plug
in so deep to content to identify all
the horrifying details until my mind
it's great
let's break down all the interesting
details and Star Wars connections that
you might have missed starting with
composer Nicholas Patel's music in the
opening it takes on a more aggressive
beat
[Music]
table five has found a Brisk Rhythm to
assemble their probable Death Star
jigsaw pieces but also Quicken the
heartbeat as we realize time is running
out for them to make a move this episode
is titled nobody's listening Exclamation
point Exclamation point to connote a
shout and we learned that the Empire
does not care to listen to us because
it's too busy drowning us out with noise
the auditory torture of this episode
takes many forms the Machinery of the
narcina 5 work floor
just shut down to the Senate pods
Authority
and here in the opening shot dead Ramiro
cracking her neck a chiropractor's dream
of course the most traumatic sound of
this episode is the one we do not hear
the torture of dysonite children's death
cry but the horror that's left to our
imagination has its own perceivable
counterpart with all the sounds of
Oppression we hear throughout this
episode the idea of the Empire silencing
voices that goes back to a New Hope
really the most haunting detail of
Imperial cruelty that stuck with me as a
kid as if millions of voices suddenly
cried out in Terror
suddenly silenced while interrogating
Bix deadra says you pull in the net and
the easy thing the quick thing is to
assume that everything you've dragged to
shore is a fish really another way of
saying when you're a hammer everything
begins to look like a nail this has been
detra's criticism of the Empire The
Empire is killing ants with Bazookas
playing right into the rebel strategy so
Dedra is saying she's more of a scalpel
Dedra goes on but I take a more nuanced
View
I try yeah she leans into whisper a very
intimate trigger her way of saying the
way we're gonna get to you is by forcing
our mouths into your ear she introduces
Dr gorse Who does his little wave of
course is the worst and she recounts
salmon Pack's backstory Hawk attended a
separatist meeting two years ago in
genre where he met a woman who suggested
that if he was serious about politics he
might like to act as liaison for ferrics
when he returned home attended a
separatist meeting two years ago and met
a woman this is a lot like how Joe
McCarthy would force people to testify
for attending meetings in college often
early just to make friends or a hookup
and he used that to label these people
Communists a separatist meeting two
years prior would be long after the
Clone Wars when separatist power was all
but snuffed out anyway presumably this
woman he met was clear Lutheran's
operative on Coruscant behind deadra and
in every ISB interrogation room is a
grid of security cameras which are the
same design that Han and Chewie shoot
out in the Death Star in a new hope not
really an earth shatter an Easter egg I
just appreciate the little continuity
details that take us back to that 70s
production design Dedra says
the very worst thing you can do right
now
poor me I love this I will be using it
in every context as a gift but there
also may be some unintentional wordplay
here Tetra doesn't want to be bored as
an uninterested but she also doesn't
want to be bored as in drilled into to
form a hole she doesn't want anyone to
bore into her protective shell and she
flashes just the tiniest bit of
vulnerability when she realizes Bix
won't confess to anything voluntarily
[Music]
got the tiniest muscle in Denise goff's
cheek contracts there and I love all the
transitions back and forth from bix's
torture to the Machinery of the prison
in this episode which always sink to
sound like Bix screaming
thank you
there's a cold but satisfying efficiency
to the way the machine parts Rise Up
from the table like a Pez dispenser you
can actually see the next one locked and
loaded under the table so who loads
those one wonders if each level could be
an assembly line passing these parts up
to the next level to become more and
more complex spaces of this death star
or whatever they are Cassian AKA Keith
notices table two short-handed but not
for long there's a new man coming down
but we can take the [ __ ] if we push
we're already up on the floor now at
first I thought casting was a converted
institutionalized man chasing those
simple rewards when in reality he's
actually clocking prisoner transfers
together Intel on the guards because
that's the only time guards come in and
out of there like luthin and manmatma
and Belle he is wearing multiple masks
to survive he's proven himself a true
clandestine Rebel oolav struggles to
keep up what do you say Old Timer short
timer he has all's Corrections so they
don't really measure time and age they
measure it in time remaining in your
sentence and by the way there is no way
ulap was labeled as able-bodied recently
suggesting that he might have been in
this prison for 7 several years maybe
even pre-empire which would be quite an
indictment on the oversight of the
Republic era he may be an old-timer who
got rotated back into a new level and
prefers institutionalization like the
tragic character of the inshawshank
Redemption alternatively we could also
see him as the evil old man in Squid
game Who spoiler warning was the true
game master of all of that but rather
than ulap as a deceitful Undercover Boss
I think a darker theory is that he was
the original Prison Architect who built
and designed all this in the Empire
imprisoned him here to keep it all a
secret Cassian swaps with taka's spot
under the guise of efficiency and even
credits toggle with the idea but it's
actually to give him an opportunity to
keep an eye on the room without having
to glance over his shoulder all
awkwardly later he sees that guard
passing overhead and uses that moment to
take a break and remember last episode
taga was the one who noticed the passing
guards overhead laughing at them gorrest
explains the origin of their
interrogation technique an audio
recording from the dysonites from daison
Frey they make a sound as they die sort
of
Coral
agonized pleading specifically The Isley
isolildren in Real World by
robot with a natural trigger to the
sound of crying children because we are
tribal creatures designed to avoid
attracting Predators the Empire has
weaponized this Instinct turning our
biological empathy for the distressed
signals of endangered children into an
interrogation technique God I hope the
CIA isn't watching the show in the
moment these headphones are put on her
is haunting
foreign
the most terrifying moment of Star Wars
the score cuts out and we brace
ourselves for the sounds of those
dysonite death screams but instead all
we hear is Big screaming this show is
using Andrea arjona's Coral agonized
pleading to torture us and the door
shuts on us and instead we follow a
guard walking past in the hallway just
like the shot of Leia being tortured on
the Death Star in A New Hope and again
this screen transitions to the prison
workload
the screams of tortured Rebels are the
same as the screams of their machines
the same as the screams of their type
Fighters we have to listen to them
scream but when we scream nobody's
listening exclamation point Cassian saws
into the Machinery in the wall of the
bathroom which is located directly
beneath the lift so this is likely part
of the Hydraulics of it you can notice a
few pass scratches on that pipe so they
have been working at this for quite some
time Cassian and this other prisoner
clock the new prisoner arrival two
guards two weapons no boots meaning the
floor of that elevator must not be
electrified In This Moment believe me
now the elevator is not wide nothing
that moves can fry you the prisoner
means no walking platform that moves but
he also implies that the roving humans
of this facility aren't the threat the
facility design is and if you can get
past that design the rest are going to
fall over like dominoes Dedra sneers
that she squeezes bix's sweaty face
looking a lot like agent Smith
interrogating Morpheus in The Matrix and
later after this interrogation her
Captain says
care I'd like to hang him yeah these
Imperials are truly sincerely disgusted
with their captives and again Pock was
just a guy who attended a separatist
meeting in college trying to get laid
now if you're full of chivalry and
really want to address someone as Lord
and Lady established titles can make it
official established titles as a Project
based on a historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
lairds or Lords and Ladies in English
they let people buy as little as one
square foot of dedicated land so that
they can call themselves a lord or a
lady in return established titles
commits to planting a tree it's just a
really fun way to help preserve the
beautiful woodlands and biodiversity of
Scotland while supporting Global A4
station efforts established titles work
with global charity trees for the future
and one tree planted to help them plant
a tree for every order Plus for those
with Scottish Heritage out there it's
just a great way to connect to your
family roots your certificate features a
unique plot Number with which you can
see the exact location of your land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland and
an official certificate with the crest
you can get a couple pack for you and
your partner with adjoining plots of
land and you can literally have this
gift ready in five minutes so it makes
an amazing last minute gift an
established titles is actually running a
massive sale right now plus if you use
the code new rockstars you get an
additional 10 off so go to established
titles.com new rockstars to get your
gifts now and help support this channel
on to the Senate Chamber Of course on
now it has an imperial Crest on the
central floor which is not during the
Star Wars prequels man magma speaks and
sharing that Central Deus is a figure
who is hard to make out from the
overhead shot you can see some blue so I
thought it could have been the grand
vizier masameda but a closer shot later
makes this guy look more human in the
background we do hear male voice
shouting
is to the citizens who have sent us here
just as matsumita did in Phantom Menace
when they were trying to recall
Chancellor valorum
there's a lot like the British
Parliament where they're all kind of
yell at each other and the speaker will
go
as mon speaks out against the por-d
other Senators Heckle things like long
live the Empire and we've heard this and
boo and I know compared this to the UK
Parliament but that's all done in
respectful jest for the most part
meanwhile in the American legislative
bodies more and more we're starting to
see the president get heckled during the
state of the union and it's not a good
thing and while there are some
supportive shouts of listen to her most
of the pods one by one switch off their
lights in protest of her words literally
making this room more and more like the
dark side says those of you who still
believe that when we enter this building
we are in a temple yes mon Likens his
Senate chamber with a temple the way the
Jedi see their temple on course on and
both of these temples will end up
desecrated by Palpatine on the bridge
tagus hand signal partner tells him that
something is going on on level two
what's he saying
yeah
another one
what was that this power surge was the
moment the guards completely fried the
100 inmates on that level 2 bridge but
this also shows that when one large
floor area gets activated power must be
redirected from the rest of the prison
which is something that they might be
able to use next episode when they break
out Kino yells at Target saying that it
takes a week for word to get from one
level to the other that's only for him
he just doubts that taka's back Channel
could communicate that fast and I think
he's really just angry that he's the
last one to know when things happen
because he's just going through proper
channels in his Network we learned that
Bell is monmouth's cousin both fighting
the Empire from different angles
spinning out of it
you took a vow a vowel it sounds like
these two embarked on this Rebel mission
after swearing a kind of oath but to
whom I'm wondering if they could have
sworn this vow at the grave of Padme
Cassian tells Kina that the guards don't
have to care about what they're saying
down there we are nothing to them
well she's right we're cheaper than
droids and he's here to replace this is
true even for the top brass of the
Empire Tarkin replaced efficient but
expensive clone troopers and replaced
them with Stormtrooper recruits even
though Stormtroopers don't know how to
aim for [ __ ] and Kino switches off his
cell light to ignore Keith the same way
the other Senators switch off their
lights to tell man mothma that they were
ignoring her Dedra updates the ISB about
stolen Imperial equipment found in a
rebel cell associated with Maya pay that
was the person who was cited last
episode by saw Guerrera as a past failed
Rebel leader deadra tries to connect
Cassie into the eldani robbery and her
Aid speaks up he was clean-shaven andal
had shaved the rebels of aldani were
clean shaven
and two soldiers from The Garrison who
got a look at him felt there was some
similarity to our reference picture yeah
they're starting to close in on all of
them realizing that the simple Act of
changing one's appearance is reason
enough to suspect wrongdoing cassian's
level learns that 100 men were fried out
and Kino snaps we finally see Aquino
realize that the system he has trusted
for so long was never trustworthy
it's another day
another shift so let's keep our mouths
shut keep our heads down
until we know what's going on Andy's
circus is so good at showing that [ __ ]
in his eyes the same ship from Defiance
to vulnerability then back to Defiance
that he brought to the performance of
Gollum I love this actor Cyril's mom
noticed that he changed his hair just
like the Imperials noticed a Cassian
shave but Zero's case is likely to
impress deadra he says he's been in my
private box
her voice of knowing a private box gross
I mean you know some hand-drawn pictures
of deadra are in there right his mom
nags shadow of a song a tenant a
stranger that's new you want to remember
that all that time away on molana what
if I'd let your neglect drive me insane
imagine that oh the Sass between these
two but the mom did not even hear him
she just kept going on and on and then
he does the same thing he slurps his
milk to drown her out again nobody's
listening let me support Bell tells them
that she's headed back to chandrilla yes
the pilgrimage I thought she was making
a joke about this just being an
obligatory visit to relatives but no the
closed captioning capitalizes pilgrimage
so this must be some chandrillan custom
like the eye of aldani it's another
religious custom something that the
Purity just raised the penalties for if
you use as a cover for Rebel activities
also I like that they're eating these
large eggs what some blue garnishes
sticking out looks yummy zero cars
stalks outside the ISB to run into Dedra
and he thanks her for his promotion at
the Bureau of Standards he tells her
she's being in your presence Cheyenne
they've realized that life was worth
living I realized that if nothing else
there was Justice perhaps my deranged
belief that there was something better
fitted for me in the future was a dream
worth clinging to yeah he clearly wrote
and rehearsed his speech a legitimately
creepy profession of love from an
unsocialized loner but let's just saying
how you do it and he says I want
since it zero poor sensitive confirmed I
mean I kind of hope he is just so an
Inquisitor gets him Dentures Aid reports
that they captured a rebel pilot and are
holding them on a destroyer outside
stearguard now the rebels don't really
have much of a fleet at this point this
really is a pilot who's just piloting
transport ships around remember we only
saw two early model x-wings outside
sagarea's Hideout but those x-wings
alone were enough for Luther to go to
him asking for some air support takeoma
tells mon that to cover a 400 000 credit
withdrawal they need a large sum deposit
alone that they'll have to get from a
thug Banker Davos golden someone will
meet next episode The ISB puts together
that the rebel pilot worked for Anto
Krieger the guy Lutheran told Sagar air
about last episode who needed that air
support on the mission to spell house
Dedra says that the pilot was on his way
to cabrin the rings of caprine was where
we first met Cassie and Andor in Rogue
one they plan to sabotage the Pilot's
ship so that it's found by the rebel
cell meaning that Anto Krieger is about
to get ambushed and Lutheran could get
outed this way ooloff suffers a stroke
right at the end of a shift and Saul has
to cover him so that he's blocked
perfectly from the line inside the
guards up above the Medtech arrives Dr
rasid played by Adrian Rollins another
actor from HBO's Chernobyl in this cast
he played the character for me he also
played James Potter in the Harry Potter
films and we see his feet on the graded
lift platform another reminder that it
is not electrified and this will
probably be their means of Escape now
Rosie says that he has seen Olaf before
and he reveals that the riot on level 2
was caused by a prisoner who had
previously been a level four and
released just to be recycled back to a
different level like melshi suggested
the number does not matter no one ever
really leaves this place and I love how
Kino calls ulap Uli he had a nickname
for him proving that he knew this old
man for a long time and had some
affection for him and now he might be
wondering if molop could have also been
recycled from a different level and
that's why he's so old and now seeing
this old man die in prison Kino realizes
that there is no hope and finally
answers cassian's question
many cards on each level
11 more than 12. now we do some math
here at seven levels that also means no
more than 84 guards in this whole
facility and probably less than that
because guards are always falling behind
but transferring between levels like who
knows maybe there's only like 30 guards
in this whole place but we know for sure
there are 100 prisoners per room 50
shifting from day to night and seven
rooms per level that's 700 per level and
then Seven Levels meaning 4 900
prisoners well maybe 4 800 now but
either way nearly 5 000 against no more
than 84 guards I mean always tell me
those odds follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
foreign
[Music]